terry pratchett novels the villainous
mentor and a tap-dancing mailman juror
for just some of the deleted characters
and rejected concepts and DreamWorks
animated movie trials in this video I'm
going to take a peek at some of the
characters and ideas that were cut from
the theatrical release of the movie
before I start I've got a second copy to
giveaway of this beautiful hardback book
from Titan called the art of DreamWorks
trolls which is packed with concept and
production art and info on the movie for
a chance to win the book subscribe and
leave a comment or reply to a comment
about the film on this video and for
some bonus ways to enter the giveaway
check out the gleam link in the video
description below for more details quick
warning there are spoilers here if you
haven't seen the film already so if you
want to avoid those you can click here
to watch my spoiler free review of the
movie the original villain for the movie
who ended up being deleted was a
character called Miss guffin in an
earlier version of the film miss Guffey
was Poppy's mentor and an elder troll
who was kidnapped by the bergen chef and
in a twist in that story it would have
been miss guffin who betrayed poppy and
the other trolls later in the film
rather than Creek who ends up as a
turncoat troll in the final movie trolls
movie producer Gina Shea said that miss
Guffey was set up to be so appealing and
funny that nobody could recover when she
turned evil although miss guffin was cut
from the movie the character wasn't
completely lost though as her design was
reused for grandma rosie perf branch's
grandmother you'll remember that grandma
Rosie Puffs appears in the final movie
in branches flashback scene where she
sacrificed herself to save branch when
he accidentally drew the Bergin's
attention because we're singing grandma
Rosie Perez voiced by youtuber glozell
green and as a nice Easter Egg to that
the character has green lips and hair
another deleted character from the movie
was the master yogi Sybil after Creek
became a more significant character in
the film civil was sadly curse although
as art director and character designer
Timothy Lau explained a loss of Sybil's
yoga and Zen elements were incorporated
into creeks character although the
trolls movie made its first official
casting in 2014 with Anna Kendrick in
the role of princess poppy the film's
history is much more complicated and
goes all the way back to 2001 when
DreamWorks Animation bought the rights
to adapt also Terry Pratchett's the No
trilogy aka the bromeliad trilogy and in
2008 they attached Slumdog Millionaire
director Danny Boyle as the director of
the planned adaptation but that was
abandoned due to the economic crisis at
the time the project was restarted in
2010 with the new director and a new
title trolls and was set to combine the
trolls toys with some elements of Terry
Pratchett's novel both Chloe Moretz and
Jason Schwartzman have been cast as
leads by this point but the story of
change so much that their caste was no
longer a good fit so the film was
completely recast starting with Anna
Kendrick and the following year in 2015
Justin Timberlake joined to voice branch
satin and chenille also known as a
fashion twins and voiced by Swedish
electro pop duo
Icona pop were originally going to have
a running joke through the movie where
they changed their clothes in every
scene for example after being captured
by the bergens they would have
reappeared dressed in prison clothes
like an orange jumpsuit
however the filmmakers ended up
abandoning the idea as it would have
been very expensive the giraffe like
Cooper is one of the most distinctive
trolls in the troll village and the
inspiration for his design came from a
set of animal type trolls that character
designer Timothy Lam discovered while
researching the history of troll toys
Bert's before the filmmakers settled on
Cooper's final design which we see in
the movie initial concept art showed him
as a mailman and a tap-dancing giraffe
when the villainous Bergen chef finds
poppy in the trolls during her
celebration party in the theatrical
release poppy is dressed in her normal
clothing however in the same scene in
the trailer she's wearing what looks
like a ceremonial robe this change
suggests that poppy was going to made
Queen much earlier in the story rather
than at the very end of the film so guys
what do you think about the deleted
characters and concepts and are there
any you think should have stayed in the
movie don't forget to subscribe and
comment for your chance to win this
gorgeous the art of DreamWorks trolls
hardback book for bonus ways to enter
the giveaway click on the gleam link in
the video description below and if you
enjoyed this video you'll also like my
15 hidden secrets and easter eggs for
the trolls movie click left here to
check those out or check out these
awesome deleted scenes from finding Dory
by clicking over there on the right
thanks for watching and see you next
time
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers